das ist ein weiterer meilenstein bei der
erforschung des mars organische moleküle
im zero krater der nasa rover providence
hat dort jetzt organische moleküle
aufgespürt eine super spannende
entdeckung und ein schritt bei der suche
nach außerirdischen leben und peer sowie
das hat auch bei der untersuchung des
gesteins im krater eine spannende
entdeckung gemacht jungs aus der
wirtschaft gegen istra mark pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke denn so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
der mars rover providence ist
offensichtlich am richtigen ort um
außerirdischen leben auf die schliche zu
kommen sein aktueller einsatzort der
riesige krater auf dem roten planeten
und tatsächlich gelang ihm jetzt eine
spektakuläre entdeckung im zentrum das
scanning happy table dance with the men
and women s dance for organic center
chemicals instrument kurzurlaub auf
deutsch scannen habitablen geben mit
rahman und prominenz für organische und
chemische stoffe spricht das instrument
ist speziell für die suche nach
außerirdischen leben gebaut worden und
damit konnten jetzt organische
kohlenstoffhaltigen verbindungen im
marsgestein nachgewiesen werden laut
nasa ist das eine zitat großartige
neuigkeit und nicht nur das die nasa
forscher haben jetzt eine weitere
spektakuläre erkenntnis veröffentlicht
denn mit der hilfe des kosovo sowas
konnte jetzt endlich eine frage
beantwortet werden die die fachwelt
schon lange umtreibt dabei geht es um
die gesteine in der landesregierung
welche ursprung haben diese sind sie
sedimentären ursprungs also war
beispielsweise fließendes wasser an der
entstehung beteiligt oder sind sie
vulkanischer natur und somit ihnen
lavaflüsse entstanden alle spannenden
erkenntnisse die jetzt mit der hilfe des
nasa mars rovers präsidiums geborgen
worden sind gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum
science in future schon der vorgänger
von providence der mars rover curiosity
konnte organische moleküle auf dem roten
planeten identifizieren vor vier jahren
2018 hatte die nasa auf einer
pressekonferenz mitgeteilt dass der
rover zitat
widerstandsfähige organische moleküle im
inneren von rund drei milliarden jahre
altem sedimentgestein aufgespürt hatte
gleich an zwei verschiedenen orten geld
krater wurden diese organischen moleküle
in dem jahr milliarden alten gestein des
mars entdeckt diese enthalten laut der
nasa fachleute unter anderem kohlenstoff
und wasserstoff und möglicherweise auch
sauer und stickstoff sowie weitere
elemente organischer materie also sehr
einfacher kohlenstoffverbindungen die
hinweise auf eine lebensfreundliche zeit
auf dem roten planeten geben konkret
handelt es sich bei der entdeckung um
aromatische khalifa tische und
telefonische verbindung möglicherweise
hat es dort also nur mal so von mikroben
gewimmelt diese entdeckung sorgte für
große aufregung weltweit doch die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
der nasa bremsten die euphorie
während diese moleküle allgemein mit
leben in verbindung gebracht werden
könnten sie aber auch durch nicht
biologische prozesse entstehen und sind
deshalb alleine noch kein eindeutiger
nachweis für einziges leben doch die
moleküle konnten in der nähe der
oberfläche des sedimentgesteins
aufgespürt werden und das spricht dafür
dass die marsoberfläche 1 zumindest
lebensfreundlich war hinzu kommen die
wirklich mysteriösem methan werte in der
mars atmosphäre die den fachleuten schon
langer zeit den schlaf rauben ist es
außerirdisches leben das für den
mysteriösen methanausstoß auf dem mars
verantwortlich ist auf der erde entsteht
methan jedenfalls durch biologische
prozesse beispielsweise wenn rinder ihre
nahrung verdauen messungen auf dem mars
hatten außerdem gezeigt dass die
konzentration des metalls das jahr über
stark schwankt ist das etwa ein beweis
für biologische aktivitäten
ausgeschlossen ist es allerdings nicht
dass das methan durch geologische
prozesse freigesetzt wird denn das gas
kann auch geochemische entstehen zum
beispiel durch die uv bestrahlung von
gesteinsmaterial nicht wenige fachleute
weltweit gehen aber davon aus dass es
sich um außerirdisches leben handelt
dass das metall sporadisch auf dem roten
planeten produziert stehen wir also kurz
vor der großen entdeckung von
außerirdischen leben auf der nasa
overpair syriens hat in diesem
zusammenhang jetzt eine spannende
entdeckung gemacht es handelt sich um
den technisch anspruchsvollste
mars-rover der jemals von menschenhand
entwickelt wurde ausgestattet ist er mit
sieben wissenschaftlichen instrumenten
23 kameras einem laser zwei mikrofonen
und einem kleinen hubschrauber sein
aktueller arbeitsort desiro krater ein
ort der zuvor noch niemals genauer unter
die lupe genommen wurde dazu der nasa
wissenschafts direktor thomas zu buchen
der riesige krater ist der perfekte ort
um nach zeichen vergangenen lebens zu
suchen so können wir verstehen wie der
mars einmal war und warum man nun so ist
wie er ist direkt nach seiner landung
anfang 2000 21 hatte der nasa oder
spannende daten zur erde gesandt mit
deren hilfe ein riesiges rätsel um den
mars gelöst werden konnte war der giro
krater einst ein see und die antwort
lautet ja dazu der nasa-forscher nicolas
mangold das ist die schlüssel
beobachtung die uns ein für alle mal
bestätigt dass es einen see und ein
flussdelta am giro prater gab jetzt
konnte mit der hilfe von personal hörens
ein weiteres großes maß mysterium gelöst
werden wie die nasa berichtete eine
große überraschung sogar für die
fachleute selbst konkret geht es um den
ursprung des mars gesteins in der
landesregierung so was ist ihre herkunft
mechanischer natur oder sind sie
sedimentären ursprungs war also
fließendes wasser an ihrer entstehung
beteiligt dazu der nasa mitarbeiter
kennt falle ich begann zu verzweifeln
und glaubte wir würden nie die antwort
finden doch dann hat unser pixel
instrument einen guten blick auf die
abgestürzte stelle eines felsens und es
wurde alles klar die kristalle im
inneren sind der unwiderlegbare beweise
pixel steht für planetary instrumente
für x-raid chemistry und es handelt sich
um ein präzisions röntgengerät mit
künstlicher intelligenz die analyse
eines steins gehen die fachleute auf den
spitznamen braig getauft hatten zeigt
ein eindeutiges ergebnis projekt besteht
demnach aus vielen olivin kristallen die
in sogenannten thyroxin kristallen
eingeschlossen sind solche eine textur
weist auf gestein hin dass gebildet
wurde als kristalle wachsen und sich in
einem langsam abkühlen markmann
niederließen denkbar wären
beispielsweise ein dicker lavastrom ein
lover see oder einem man kann man seine
zusammensetzung offenbart also dass der
mars untergrund des lokals aus glühend
heiße magma geformt wurde und danach ist
dieser stein dann wohl mehrmals von
wasser verändert worden so die nasa
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
satzung der nasa-forscher kämpfen er
wurde so zu einer schatzkiste des
künftigen vorstellungen möglich macht
ereignisse im seo auch grad zu datieren
umgekehrt ist allerdings noch die frage
ob das untersuchte gestein in einem
lover see an der oberfläche ausgekühlt
ist oder in einer unterirdischen kammern
die später durch erosion an die
oberfläche kam möglicherweise kann
dieses rätsel aber gelöst werden wenn
percy wir uns ein stück des gesteins bei
einer künftigen mission mit zur erde
bringt und es hier genauer unter die
lupe genommen werden kann zu einer
weiteren spektakulären überraschung hat
ein weiteres instrument des masters
geführt sherlock nämlich hat die zero
krater organische verbindungen
aufgespürt nicht nur um geld sondern
auch im seo krater sind also organische
verbindungen im alten hmas gestein
erhalten geblieben die große chance
besteht also weiterhin potenzielle
virensignaturen auf dem mars aufzuspüren
als zeichen für einstiges oder
möglicherweise heute noch aktives leben
doch klar ist auch dass dieser fund
nicht automatisch bedeutet dass es hier
im visier krater unbedingt mal leben
gegeben haben muss die nasa fachleute
betonen dass das biologische als auch
nicht biologische mechanismen gibt bei
denen organische verbindungen entstehen
dennoch ist der aktuelle fund eine
spannende erkenntnisse dazu heißt es von
der us raumfahrtbehörde nasa mit dem
sherlock instrument können wir nun
erstmals die räumliche verteilung dieser
organischen moleküle im gestein und
damit deren verhältnis zur ebenfalls
vorhandene mineralien untersuchen das
wiederum hilft uns die umweltbedingungen
besser zu verstehen die einst zur
entstehung der organischen verbindungen
geführt haben jetzt sind weitere
analysen notwendig um zu verstehen wie
die identisch sie zielten verbindung 1
entstanden sein könnten auch hier wird
eine analyse auch der erde weitere
fragen klären können platz der
nasa-forscher loser beagle der erhalt
von organischen verbindungen ist sehr
aufregend wenn diese maske zur erde
gelangen werden sie für viele jahre eine
quelle für die wissenschaftliche
forschung waren und auch bei methan hat
sicher 2021 etwas getan leben auf dem
mars curiosity hat methan rätsel gelöst
tatsächlich ist der mars rover der
lösung des methans rätsels einen
riesigen schritt näher gekommen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran